thanks for staying with us there's a new
study out that's warning of the possible
deadly consequences for teens using
social media teen suicide rates had been
declining for decades but new data from
the Centers for Disease Control shows
that the numbers went up between 2010
and 2015 now we don't know the exact
reason for the uptick but a new study in
the journal of clinical psychological
studies suggests it might have something
to do with a sharp rise of the use of
social media joining us now for reaction
from Boston is psychotherapist Karen
Ruskin and in Grand Rapids Michigan
pediatrician meg maker our eighth doctor
maker let's talk to you first what have
you seen in your clinical practice on
this issue do you see a connection
between social media and these types of
you know pathological or suicidal
tendencies yeah well first of all thanks
for having me on Laura you know I'm so
glad that you brought this up and I do
see a connection between teen depression
and social media in my practice as a
matter of fact today I just talked with
a young girl who is struggling with very
serious depression and depression and
teenagers is very serious
how can it be related to social media
depression and a teen is all about the
self hating the self deep down
subconsciously teens don't like who they
are so we can see how being on social
media Instagram in particular teenagers
see other kids they look at the picture
of the other kid girls in particulars
say I'm not as thin I'm not as pretty
I'm not as attractive as she is and so
they start to feel worse about who they
are so you know I really see and I've
actually had teenagers tell me that
being on Instagram makes them feel worse
and so for some of the teenagers that I
treat with depression I with their
cooperation actually put them on a diet
from social media to guard them if you
will from feeling worse than they
already do so for me personally I see a
very clear connection between social
media and teen dr. Shuren dr. Ruskin my
I have a daughter who's 12 and you know
she said when you're gonna get a phone
and I say how does never sound to you I
mostly do everything I can I borrow a
friend's phone but I'm just I'm
petrified of this and I guess I'm the
boring mother and I don't know if I'm
petrified of it and maybe I'm wrong to
be petrified of it but I find what I see
among kids yeah it's not good it's not
good
you're not wrong Laura and the fact is
as parents as a parent myself of a
teenager and as a psychotherapist it's
imperative that we create ground rules
for social media for an example the
phone at night must not be in the room
that's the bottom line we're still
parents and we forget that sometimes
when it comes to kids in social media
the consistence
and frequency of looking at social media
instead of living your life that can
lead to depression not being able to
escape from the world the bedlam of the
everyday hustle bustle of socialization
home used to be a safe haven it's not
anymore because the appendage known as
social media the phone comes home with
you everywhere so as a parent we must
talk with them about their social media
relationship we must talk with them
about health and wellness and suicide
and not be afraid to because parents are
often afraid to have those hard to talk
about talks and if you're afraid to talk
about it your kids gonna be afraid to
talk about it that's that's an excellent
point I want to play for you something
that one of the original funders of
Facebook Shawn Parker said recently
about its addicting quality let's watch
that thought process was all about how
do we consume as much of your time and
conscious attention as possible and that
means that we need to sort of give you a
little dopamine hit every once in a
while it's a social validation feedback
loop that that it's like I mean it's
exactly the kind of thing that a that a
hacker like myself would come up with
because you're exploiting a
vulnerability in in human psychology all
right quick reaction from both of you
dr. Meeker Sean Parker he knows
technology what's your thought he does
and you know it's very dangerous and
very addictive and I
want to say something first of all never
parent out of fear parents are so afraid
to pull social media out of their kids
lives to make their kids put the phone
in the kitchen plugged in at nighttime
so afraid to tell their kids look half
an hour of social media a day is all you
get but let me tell you something your
kids are worth fighting for my kids are
adults now and I was very strict with
screen time which was TV in those days
and they are so grateful if you can be
strong enough to parent well and say to
your kids look these are my rules my
phone no privacy we need to restrict
social media you will be doing your kids
such an enormous favor so don't be
afraid do what's right for your kids dr.
Ruskin very quickly to close this out he
Sean Parker says it's exploiting a
vulnerability in human psychology human
beings by our very nature
we are addictive we are impulsive we are
reactive so definitely there is a lure
in for social media as parents it's all
about helping kids to create a healthy
balance because social media has its
advantages it's just about having a
healthy balanced extremism in any
direction is unhealthy we must control
our controllables alright guys great to
see you the doctors were in thank you